[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con aquí en
france 24 en chile se cumple un año
desde que se detectó el primer caso de
ccoo y 19 en el país una nación cuenta
con más de 800 33.000 contagios y 20 mil
600 muertes y lidera la vacunación
contra el virus en la región nos
acompaña entonces heriberto garcía
escorza director del instituto de salud
pública de chile gracias por estar con
nosotros esta mañana en este día y
cuéntenos chile lidera la vacunación en
américa latina' 18 de cada 100
habitantes han recibido el suero contra
el coronavirus en menos de un mes más de
tres millones de personas han recibido
también ya la primera dosis en que
radica el éxito de la inmunización de
los ciudadanos en chile
hola buenos días primero que todo si
efectivamente nosotros estamos en esa
cantidad hoy día de inauguraciones y
tiene que ver básicamente con la
coordinación que hemos tenido entre las
instituciones tanto el gobierno del
punto de vista del trabajo que ha hecho
la cancillería con las diferentes
negociaciones con diferentes
laboratorios a su vez el ministerio de
salud que realizaba muy bien estos
contratos y todo el trabajo también que
hemos hecho comentó solo pública
específicamente en los controles de
calidad y en las autorizaciones
sanitarias que le ha gustado estas
vacunas para que sean usadas ahora bien
es muy importante y relevante el trabajo
también que se hace cuando está
vacunando y el trabajo que hace la
atención primaria de salud y el programa
nacional de inmunizaciones que es son
programas que tenemos hace años digamos
en chile y que funciona bastante bien y
con bastante éxito en nuestras campañas
chile también es una de las economías
más abiertas de américa latina' cómo es
que este sistema de salud
afecta en el contexto y cómo es un éxito
entonces la campaña de vacunación
teniendo en cuenta esos dos factores
lo que pasa es que nosotros voy a
enfocar específicamente a salud que es
lo que nosotros manejamos como míster
pública específicamente nosotros tenemos
una muy buen trabajo en materia de
atención primaria salud que une un
sistema muy bien armado que se comenzó
el año 60 y el año 80 pasó a los
municipios y en los los municipios
tienen un muy buen sistema con el
conocimiento acabado digamos el modelo
cero familiar con sus vecinos y al
conocer a sus vecinos y tenerlos
listados pueden facilitar bastante lo
que el llamado a los vecinos para la
vacunación y aceptó este control y es
por eso que yo creo que también tenemos
este éxito este éxito está muy enfocado
también al buen trabajo que hace el
personal de salud de atención primaria
de los consultorios precisamente esa es
la siguiente pregunta para que nos
amplió un poco la inoculación contra el
coi 19 en el país es gratuita y es
voluntaria
el gobierno chileno apostó por la
diversificación de las dosis del suero
como ha sido la estrategia de
adquisición y distribución de la
vacunación en el país
primero todo el trabajo dedicado cierto
de parte de la gran civilidad para
lograr los acuerdos comerciales con los
diferentes laboratorios luego de esos
acuerdos a los cuales solo pública ya
participaba como asesor básicamente en
salud viene todo un proceso donde en el
fondo nosotros tomamos la decisión en el
caso por ejemplo es si novak que es la
vacuna que con la quema de modo
inoculado con chile de ir a hacer la
visita inspectiva al laboratorio de este
si no bajen china de manera tal de poder
hacerle los controles de calidad y saber
que sencillamente cumple con las buenas
prácticas manufacturas y después viene
el proceso de autorización donde se
evalúa calidad desde el punto de vista
de la empresa tecnológica de punto de
vista es contract y calidad del punto de
vista de la fabricación y producción de
revista seguridad y eficacia de punto de
vista en los medios clínicos y se toma
la decisión digamos de que la buena que
se va a usar el killer autorizaron
incluso lo publica el gobierno del
presidente sebastián piñera dijo que
pretende vacunar al 80 por ciento de su
población a finales del primer semestre
del año siendo un ejemplo para otros
países
la región méxico colombia perú paraguay
también han pedido ayuda a las
autoridades chilenas y entonces
cuéntenos qué enseñanzas deja esta
campaña de vacunación en chile para las
demás naciones
bueno básicamente el poder coordinar muy
bien lo que son los abastecimientos para
que vayan llegando las vacunas en las
fechas que bueno estima estima
conveniente para ir cumpliendo con el
calendario es decir la semana pasada ya
estábamos con con vacunas alrededor de
200.000 unidades y teníamos que
inmediatamente recibir ya los 4 millones
para partir la segunda dosis que parte
hoy día justamente en la campaña de la
campaña de vacunación y eso obviamente
requiere que nosotros como instituto y
ahí la agencia reguladora de los otros
países también lo hacen tenemos bastante
ágiles en la religión de los grupos pues
agradecemos a heriberto garcía escorcia
desde chile por estar en 5 minutos con
ustedes continúen con más en france24
punto com
[Música]